this program is brought to you by emory
university please come I owe you an
extra one out of my life please sit here
cutie yes thank you well actually it's
been perfect i was just saying that
because it's given everybody a chance to
know each other more thank you and I
discussions are already happening and
since we're local we need to know each
other well that's good right yeah that's
how it's great hi yes you're my own
sister I know yeah she's an immigration
attorney works in seattle sarah coming
two days everyone got that feet long and
said ok so what we thought we would do
and we're going to really launch into it
ok is to have each person very briefly
introduce themselves to you say that you
know for sitting and blood ebel very
briefly and then we've been discussing
some of the questions that people had
for you oh really ah yes but we are also
thinking that you will you will
logically naturally have questions for
it for these folks as well because
they're doing such interesting work know
if you could be their chance that you
would have no time for questions so we
may have the public talk later and so
everybody is aware that George is
filming ok
rolling right now okay and my job is
going to be a very light handed loving
compassionate moderator okay and so I
would love to start opposite us with
Catherine Kathy Allen and if you would
pray introduce yourself to Kathy Allen
you're thinking about that hey I'm the
psychologist at Donelson Correctional
Facility in Bessemer Alabama mm-hmm I'm
the one who's been helping putting on
the courses that we had their candy
versus the psychologist yes yes mm-hmm
Alexis chase and I've the warden at
emmanuel women's facility the newest
women's prison in the state of Georgia
which opened on march twenty first of
the maximum capacity of 560 females
minimum of medium security with eight
years and less to serve sorry boy needed
to cyllage about you to use every moment
for Hollywood look I know I'm an
attorney who puts people behind bars
short and sweet sir my name is Sarah
vidarena I'm a graduate student here
dissertation research also have been
incarcerated and also working Ron
Cavanaugh's record treatment with
Alabama Department of Corrections and
the time is that in 2000 2002 we started
a 10-day by passing a course at
Donaldson correctional facility which
has survived with its ups and downs the
job dr. Allen is now running the program
the demo brothers came from that yes
Donnison I just got a copy of it to see
I'm haven't seen it is neither seen it
yet okay yeah yeah we're piggybacking
off of everything you've done getting
forward forward a beacon we are running
marathons aunty I ever show will it be I
do work with the CBC t program here at
Emory it's the cognitively based
compassion training they've been doing
work for about five year well since 2005
so six years now studying the effects of
compassion meditation on different
groups of people everything from healthy
adults to children in the foster care
system traumatized populations like
suicide survivors I'm now working with a
group that is getting ready to work to
deliver meditation training to people
who are incarcerated here in Georgia so
we're happy now the first program rolled
out by unity you remember Terry last
night perhaps Terry civility Derek their
colleagues to get it right
and I'm territorial yes you know I think
all right good and I'm sitting at this
table because I'm lucky is what I would
say and I teach I'm a Buddhist inside of
this I teach but the same especially
socially engaged buddhism yes my love
and my passion so thank you so much Lisa
this is Ron's wife yes and Alexis's
sister I don't water my father gave him
and so I just thought we were having
some really fascinating discussions
before you came and I'd like to just
open it up I think there were some
questions first Kathy you brought us
some interesting information if you
would here with data because a piece I
think of what you all are doing is so
interesting is you're actually doing
research if on the results right and I'd
love to hear something about that and
maybe some questions you might have
about the University of Alabama has just
submitted a manuscript based on mark
probably two years of ongoing research
with the faux pas sauna grouping for
publication so we're hoping that'll be
punished quickly research staff
all the same types of things mindfulness
human studies about the about the
effects of Awesome and we're real
excited because we really would like to
have a dorm we'd also like to have boba
meditation center that we get other
inmates come from other dorms and then
you know come to dumps and sort of
attend a course and we're just seeing
such great you know great effects of
that courses so the results have read
that they have substantial effects yes
ma'am we've had I've said earlier we had
15 10 de courses we've had 21 de courses
and three three day course as well to me
that a new students have been 217 but
the total students have completed
courses including all students and
servers have been 484 it's a big thing
order to such published is it on neck it
will be me it releases that consent to
you I'd ungrateful I can send it to you
and let you see what they are saying
they have a good development of the
history of meditation Transcendental
Meditation also month thanks meditation
and they have a good intro to it
pretty proud and excited about this and
this is one program it costs you nothing
financially exactly well that's quite a
word he loves it it's a great treatment
program I mean seriously it's a
treatment program that cost very little
and has great results and in fact it
goes nothing if you ask me because the
teacher the meditation teachers they are
expected to take nothing yes you can't
even give them a small gift to know
their volunteers yes an apologist from
the north of North America Bob Watson
prison for us because I remember I made
a mistake once when I and when I did the
program even for the police officers and
I wanted to give them a gift in the end
they rejected it the count even they
don't even want a gift in return this is
they so above all this so therefore can
actually cost you nothing only space and
add a part of the schedule right we're
very lucky that we have a physical plant
that can handle our meditation course
where the people three world people can
come in and live Matt the you know live
during the course with the inmates that
a lot of prisons don't have that
possibility should i do right this could
excellent for women prison oh we're
excited about that we're hoping we have
a women's prison um that we're hoping to
expand into some new areas we're hoping
to get the women started out within a
year you know you were saying something
about this beforehand some of the
research that you've heard about this
topic of women yeah I'd have to I can't
say the exact paper i'll have to get you
that information but they found studies
have been done with over 2,000 inmates
male and female what they found was the
effect for female inmates actually was
more beneficial and over time at three
and six-month period they found that
they retain more of the beneficial
results self-reporting improved state
mental health emotional satisfaction
happiness
more positive relations with people that
they were socially connected more more
social connection so and also especially
female inmates that were yet more than
men and especially if they had
substance-abuse challenges publisher
experiences men and women differences
that's exactly line that's why I said it
would be much more beneficial for women
to retain this small because in the heat
the higher emotional factor of them but
I was going to say doing the course and
then keeping up the practice is vital so
once you make them do the course and hop
I'm sure and how do you keep up enable
them to keep up the practice like doing
the one-dayers full one day programs a
week and keeping up the practice morning
and evening as they say in the course
and prisoners have enough time if you
factor it in their day schedule they can
factor it they can put it in its you and
I have got multitasking to do if
prisoners don't they once you make a
brilliant schedule they will stick to
this and you know this is what is
happening now in in prison they put
because we set a practice place and
particle part of the day work they some
of them repeated the course and when
they repeated the course many times over
they evolved and they repeated it so
many times that some of them became
eligible to become assistant teachers
so the prisoners you're kidding the
prison system now the president prison
has its own assistant but you're in this
is part of their annual she's saying to
train our goal is to train over a course
a period of time and then have people
who have worked with meditation for a
long time train them and teaching their
their peers they you know what let me
let me let me inform you little more you
and I do not make appoint them as
teachers it's a big fashion institute
fish to us and they have certain rules
and regulations how many courses see so
I can't teach you I can only share with
you what I think about the partner but I
cannot be a teacher till I'm consider to
be a teacher by david fashion or
research institute so therefore those of
them who done number of courses and done
some long courses they become assistant
teachers so therefore we need to if we
keep up the practice and if once you
keep up the practice those people will
be inclined to do own for another course
and then a longer course then the one
day you may work void for a longer
course which makes them ready to become
assistant teachers now those who are on
long-term imprisonment would be would be
very good to be inducted into such
programs and then you will have an
in-house resource of your own one day
three years from now but if that's only
if you begin now in our present we
didn't get them immediately we caught
them over the years and now it is a good
turn around doing this amazing one-third
of our inmates and Donald's on our life
without parole so they're going to be
here until they die there were loads you
can literally let them die liberate it
if you do these programs that you are
literally setting
free while in the present because this
program truly sets you free while you
are physically not free you're mentally
free so if once you promote this program
from that point of view and then also
gain the the advantage of the assistant
teachers Monday if they do so well and
then he will even one day go for longer
courses what it is 60 days which right
there so that will happen but remember
after doing the course and sure if you
can is a part of their day schedule is a
practice our both morning and evening
and then having one day courses for
months maybe the teacher will come back
and do one month go like i SAT of course
one are SATA program one are my kingdom
friends here do one program a one day or
per month we have three group settings
during the week in which we have time
for people to come together and you know
it's that the old students coming in and
sitting together but most of the old
students use it twice a week I mean
twice a day they are morning and evening
time before if that's part of the
schedule saying as soon as you finish
that's your new rate schedule you know
they they will continue to grow exact
they spiritually crew but it's excellent
for women if you can do this other
questions or comments how about from the
administrative point of view in order to
keep our program intact one of the
things that we struggle with and we're
the bible belt in the deep south and so
it's real easy for people to get
confused at the program is buddhist or
rather than just being secular or that
people get real envious and jealous over
the success of the program
it's like you're saying the inmates are
actually improving that's really not
part of their agenda for anybody to get
better necessarily other than just
warehousing people so anytime you see
that different from the norm all of a
sudden it throws everything else into a
tizzy or a panic and it's easy for the
administration that need your reaction
to just want to ship things down and I'm
wondering how is it that we can better
sell it to the administration that in
fact this is a viable program without
all that that baggage of it being a
Buddhist or they're constantly fighting
you know with the the chaplain service
things like job you know so what it's
just as just another program and it just
happens to be a very successful program
as the head of the head of this program
has been saying that this is not a
conversion program it is a program which
makes you better Christian a better
Hindu a better muslim and a better human
being you go back to your practice of
reading the Bible excellent go back to
read the Quran excellent so it does not
bar you from carrying on your earlier
practices the choices are yours but the
only thing is that load for those 10
days it is non absolutely non
ritualistically van in encourage you to
read it right it is so much of inward
but i think this sec the key to the
successes some staff members doing they
become the advocacy not the prisoners
that's where i had a breakthrough in the
heart by my deli prisoner we started
with some staff members and its staff
members when they did it they became the
advocacy saying if we could benefit so
much here those who were overflowing
with with so much of negative negativity
would be benefiting the most so i think
it that's
that's good have you all had staff
members know you both have done courses
but what about got each other students
right we've we've had a correctional
officer sit the course and
classification people and a drug
treatment counselors at the course and
we're trying to get done more officers
now this is divorce but I bet that would
probably do you imagine doing that
getting some of your yes I could I'm
just sitting here because we are so
brand new this is something that would
fall it would be perfect for the setup
for Emanuel women's facility but my
question you're the psycho educational
programming that's mandated a lot of
times by the parole board that they have
to have substance of these classes that
they have to have motivation for change
cognitive restructuring classes how can
we fit that in so that that is equated
to the same as a psycho-educational
plants and the thing is it would have a
major impact on the possibility of
reducing recidivism cordless program
mindfulness not into fashion let the
partially the technique but call it
mindfulness and I you know I've been
into substance abuse treatment program
for 23 years I ran a one of the
organization for that it's all about the
mind because the kind of psychological
changes these people go through the most
substance abusers it's all back to
neurons its biological and it's
psychological and this program addresses
them actually devices the mind so call
it mindfulness and factor it in and let
this be the technique and there's so
much scientific evidence now to back
this up you know that I mean the people
that you're thinking of working with
have so much importance like the
residence and you're working on it now
too one of the things that you have here
Karen is
some information about what com has done
right some of their scientific case
studies etc so you know right because
any work 11 I just think bring in people
I was running an hour meditation program
on mindful air quality rational
intelligence give it to me yeah
emotional intelligence yeah it's
rational intelligence is another
technique you can call it emotional
intelligence but I think you could
switch between the two and use the
sticky or mine detoxification my
compression is called mind detox because
you see the rest of the programs are all
externally they're not experience they
told this is experienced as went down
the program that's why we speaking those
who those of us who have not done the
program it's still external information
but once you practice it you know what
we it's experienced and experience so
therefore that's the best change what
would be something that would give them
the impetus to go through the program
and know that there was some type of
support out in the community what could
we offer support first of all short of
the Phillies let want to you it's about
the power of the big jr it's sure than
the movies show them dhamma brothers
show them changing from inside show them
it's hot changing doing time doing
should've these films such a selfish or
so you would start saying you wanna do
it can we try it so those are the people
who keep and then after these people who
do it would become say hey I benefited
what about you try what do you lose you
anyway 10 days inside view from this
word to another world you're not losing
anything because you are so you're not
being deprived or family time you back
here it's what time shifting from what
one to what do so that's how you know so
in the process you gaining more in these
10 days time and listen there is no
combustion you can reject what you saw
in those 10 days time this is no
compulsion but the seeds which you have
been shown for those 10 days will not go
their petition I've seen many people
doing the course they didn't like it
first they didn't like it you know what
they give it back after a year suddenly
it called the back room it just started
a different mm-hmm so I've seen
happening in my cops it happened in
prisons it happens to those of us on the
outside too right yes but no one like
other first course understood no one
likes the first three days so I can tell
you the key to my success in my program
was preparing people well as to prepare
people saying the first three days don't
give up it's going to be dry you're not
going to see Jesus Christ universi put
her there and you're not seeing the God
Almighty but first three days hang on
but if you follow this constructor
instructions of the teacher you will
make a breakthrough the fourth day to
everybody what do you open up with it
real nice Oh dr. Grady had told us for
three days and by the fourth day they're
into it more by the fifth day but those
who are not prepared we've not been told
the first three days will be dry yeah
that's a tough time they lose out of the
first three days and they want to catch
up the next three days and it's a lot of
loss of time so key to get partial
success to my mind is making them
understand that first three days follow
the instructions be a good student and
just add your benefit and I've notice
anybody who came up and said thank you
for having told us that otherwise we
would have walked out the fourth date
first okay
yeah dr. Betty and Alexis you would
mention this the support after the
release it it seems as if especially
here in the US meditation is offered to
typically wealthy communities in
typically locations where the income
level is high access to transportation
is very plentiful access even to just
all of the support that they would need
their people are able to take off work
if they're higher income however it
seems like the people who are
incarcerated they don't fit that mold so
what would you suggest for these people
who are going through these programs and
then being released like you said eight
years is the longest term and they're
coming back into their community they're
coming back into all the stressors the
same family situation the same
connections everything that the drugs
contributed to their bad decision-making
in rural communities you know what does
the first time a brilliant question of
this kind of being asked and that sets
me thinking even for back home which we
didn't think on this one but this is he
a new need which is emerged which means
you need post-release meditators group
that is there is a need for formation of
a post-release meditators group it's
like the Narcotics Anonymous or the
alcoholic alcoholics anonymous but you
now need a post filiz meditators group
which was not which is not the need
which has been expressed in New Delhi or
elsewhere why because they know where to
go in India they know where to go three
and the family also takes them back in
the community is very supportive
culturally here they may feel very
isolated and abandoned that we then need
to band together as meditators and
become a support group to each other and
i can tell you once they do that with a
passion institute may lend a helping
hand
but true nothing stops them from going
for that course in that meditators
enrolling nothing stops them they just
have to go to the website and enroll
themselves as meditators and there's no
cost for that only thing is they have to
reach that center after that the food is
free and everything is free but it's
such of course there in the end you
don't want to walk out free you want to
leave a contribution for the for the
food you ate because you are eating out
of the cost somebody else paid for so
you want to leave at least that cost so
that the program goes on but there is
nothing being asked for so that means
the meditators can be told that here are
the website following centers if you
want to continue and need to link go and
do your next course by going to the
website and enrolling yourself and they
will become part of that community but
still it's good if you can start
creating a database where you create a
meditators group so that they can group
linked with each other because they
would get understand each other better
hmm we haven't heard from you Sara who's
dealing with resiliency both inside and
outside of Prisons so how does this
relate what question might you have well
I was wondering in addition to
meditation what other sorts of
strategies have you
you come across that have been helpful
for women I know that I had gone to
Emanuel women's facility few weeks ago
it's a group of people and me in various
presentations on my particular
presentation was about some of the
findings of my own research and that
included a lot of kind of personal
resilience strategies on how to deal
with difficult times and in addition to
kind of seeking out social supports and
what I found is that a lot of a lot of
the ways in which women employee these
kind of strategies are through the
Christian faith a lot of programming
within the prison's as you mentioned our
faith-based programs and ran tree
programs are oftentimes Christian faith
based as well and I'm just wondering how
maybe there might be some other ways of
connecting this in addition to kind of
branding this as mindfulness but other
ways that we can connect what we have
now the store infrastructure we have
which is oftentimes Christian faith
faith based programming with the
mindfulness but as well as maybe some
other kind of ways that serve as links
for people so that we can make best use
of the structures we have now and the
people who are volunteering now so that
everything can
a little bit more huh what do you allow
a lot of nonprofit organizations
individuals and volunteers with security
clearance incredible people coming into
the prison yes we could excellent if
that comes I don't know if you've seen
this book this is my American edition
book of urgent she got it sorry got it
from ms amazon this is the book which
has a chapter on but it tells you the
lot of shares with you lots of other
things which I did so this is one but
secondly what is important is where it
worked worked exceedingly well from you
made that prison management task also
easier was how do we remain occupied I'd
never gave them free time but I engage
them in interesting things with the den
cells got attracted to so there was a
schedule it's not a bootcamp concept but
it's a managed a concept where then they
started with the yoga therapies and he
started with glasses and he started with
vocational skills and then they had a
spiritual discourse or an entertainment
in the evening and he had a sport so it
was like absolutely a well managed a the
way we did when we were growing up we
exactly new now it's good time it's a
playtime it's a study time and it's
family time and now it's just sleep
tight something like that but it's a
fitness time so the this is what had
done in the prison now all those things
required resources and as I explained I
did not go to the government asking for
finance because then my by the time the
finance had come if it at I would write
out of the system because my I would
have run out to my tenure and so I
didn't want to wait that long because
people's time can't wait so I brought in
everything through nonprofit
organizations and volunteers so even the
management of supposing there is a
Christmas time or there is a Easter or
there's another event you would want to
celebrate I linked it with nonprofit
organizations who gain and help them
tada see so I even had a fashion show
inside the prison so where when they
were doing learning to design clothes
they designed their clothes and we had a
fashion show so the point is it's
opening up their world within that small
world so so ensure see how can use and
you know what I've noticed every
prisoner comes into the prison culture
and the prison culture is already
predetermined a prisoner does not come
and change the culture prisoner comes
into the time schedule so if you already
have a culture the prisoner of etcetera
but if you don't have one then he then
change them later it's very tough so
first effort is move towards a culture
so the you know after all nobody stays
forever so if you can develop a culture
to be good but that's called time
management that's why this program would
fit so perfectly because we opened
without them coming in the first week
they started coming in the second week
so while in both they were retrofitting
the infrastructure all of that's going
on with building and reshaping the
facility and they're still coming and
they're still coming in and we didn't
have programs for them that's it do you
have the face you in prison where you
could do things like contemplative
practice oh definitely we have a
multi-purpose area and we also have a
program's building that has two sides in
fact that's the side that Miss Betty
Reno and her fellow associates utilized
when they came and they did the program
that Saturday there was 61 women that
participated and I have to say this
those 61 women apparently went and told
everybody else and I have a stack like
this that want to participate in the
next and it was a very positive image
and all 61 of those women attend all of
the faith-based programs because I've
been keeping a little watch even friday
night when i when i started counting
they're still going to all the
faith-based and they are starting to
internally work on themselves but they
really appreciated that and the fact
that it came from for young ladies with
our median age being 30 to 39 it's
perfect yeah
another thing with you talked about
these younger women which which again
helped me because I'm only to sharing
with you practices which worked for me
at no cost basis I tapped the talent of
each one it was at a latent within see
they've come with weather with an
aberration of her committing a crime
which is to be judged or judged already
but you also have a talent so how do
they give the talent how do the sheer
talent somebody is a singer somebody is
a dancer somebody is a painter somebody
has each one comes with a skill so we
still have a skills declaration workshop
say i have this you i am so we're not
talking about crimes we talking about
your skill so you see the positive side
of them was now resurfacing and then we
brought in who can share and teach one
means creating a resource of your own so
you don't only have to wet depend on
external resource there is an internal
resource 10,000 prisoners in my prison
many of them came with a writing a thumb
impression they could not right nobody
left with the thumb impression teachers
came from within prisoners became
teachers because when i found out the
graduate teachers say he has a teacher
tap plan would you like to be a teacher
of course everybody wanted heard laughs
it's a teacher mother suddenly is a
teacher not a robber I knew the guy was
a robber but the world now says teacher
so he walked like a teacher he talked
like a teacher and he is to get books
the evening before these are the books
for preparation for tomorrow so the guys
all the time reading and preparing for
tomorrow because now its dignity self
respect so remember to tap the talent
from good deal but we sometimes
underestimate sometimes what we have we
must that's a very funny thing when we
start when the prisoners start to come
in because when the policy changed
rather than see what crime have you
committed nobody dared ask you know what
crime is committed how much did you
clear to die you what is the other
talent you have the form was being
filled he's educated but to be a teacher
he's a music teacher but to go to music
class
dr. me one of my image has said that if
you keep them responsibility for
opportunities to take responsibility
they really grow that's what it's an
environmental factor you don't we don't
need another PhD research on it it's
known see what applies to you remember
it applies to us too while PhD will
close this research will close the issue
will establish that why wait till till
the data the point is this exactly what
I saying while you do need research but
the prisoners are there with you for
time please don't let it slip waiting
for data data is probably going to
establish what you're saying but go by
your hunch and put in these practices
imagine if two years I've waited for
data I would have ended up with nothing
so I went by my hunch that what's wrong
if i say educate what's wrong if i ask
for talent what's wrong if i put them in
class of music what's wrong if i made
make a teacher and educator what's wrong
nothing till the data establishes that
what I'm doing is the right thing so I
think you may have to take these these
good management decisions would you like
to have the data though to provide for
other people outside absolute you
understand that this is evidence-based
treatment America yeah and I'm proud
that we're getting you know to do that
it's not slowed us down or anything like
that I think one of the first things you
said to me in the car was you recognize
it's more bureaucratic here perhaps
there's less freedom there aren't as
many loopholes that you can kind of
manipulative evil are getting is that
but I'm very well bureaucratic yes but
there's many more loopholes within that
bureaucracy right yeah it's tremendously
bureaucratic param anything it's exactly
what you're saying like in our situation
if we would have waited for approval it
would never happen you simply have to do
Thanks and then let the chips fall where
they may and then the research catches
up with you the officer is going through
the courses catch up with you the
inmates who actually complete the course
and start practicing the lifestyles
catch up with you and then the proof
shows itself and then all the other
things but you actually do have to take
the initiative it's like what I try to
explain to the professors that come in
and do some of the research that are
waiting on funding i said if you're
waiting on funding to write this paper
it's never going to get rid I said let's
just go ahead and do it and then it gets
back to the bureaucracy it's like well I
can't get started until I have the IRB
approval and for the funding and it's
just like well we'll be here and we'll
start doing this but that's exactly
right and it really then gets into the
whole correctional environment or
culture where you have to overcome the
inertia and you have to overcome the
resistance of that change to be able to
say no we're going to do this program
and then that's the only way to get it
started at least in our system is to
start doing it see if you notice some
management practices cost you nothing
it's your own attitude so while I had
great respect for PhD i'm a PhD myself i
proceeded action to the confirmation of
what i was doing as a police officer I
sawn into absolutely a relationship
between drug abuse and domestic violence
and I was researching on Bonnie
performance appraisal I done already to
an hour here as a performance of present
studies at the Indian Institute
technology social sciences department I
changed it I said that's to drive for me
I'm seeing domestic violence and drug in
his relationship nobody's writing about
it talking about I want to see whether
it's in it how intense is a relationship
but meanwhile i found the practical
solutions what i wanted to start to do a
research the hypothesis proved right
that there is a predictive relationship
between drug reviews and domestic
violence and the ninety four point six
percent drug addicts commit domestic
ones and then what established further
was which what was
hunch was women as crime victims because
they are soft targets see so what I'm
saying is quick great respect to PhD but
as managers we can't afraid to let
others time slip out of hands because we
are managers of their time so by when
you're doing a talent hunt even if it's
not established yet by data it's not
costing you anything by by realizing the
potential of people and let it be
expressed and then use to the prison
they're kind of sad things about it is
that that for some reason we need to
make a case that you know that there is
a population of human beings that that
deserve the deserve access to resources
that deserve to be treated like human
beings that deserve you know to be able
to meditate if they if they if they
choose to meditate I mean I think that's
where the ironic the ronic kind of
barrier to a lot of the kind of
programming that it seems like a lot of
us are interested in doing is that
somehow there's this culture that these
people don't deserve anything that they
deserve to be exact punished and they
deserve to actually be without and I
think that that's that's where if we
could just kind of shift that culture of
mostly the people on the outside that
that we should never have to argue for
you no access to meditation
we should never have to make the case
that people deserve to be called you
know women or men instead of inmates or
density of sir you know dr. chase
actually one of the things that I
noticed that when I walked into purpose
and is that you know the officers and
more to chase when she was referring to
the woman she referred to them as ladies
and one of the women that was
incarcerated there came out to me and
kind of with tears in her eyes and said
this is the first time anyone has ever
called meridian like 15 years and and
you know and I've only been you know in
mate do this in Mako here in may go
there and I she said that I've forgotten
that I was elated and and I think that
you know that's where it's really really
powerful that we're forgetting that
people internalize the way that we're
treating them and if we could really
just shift on our side of things you
know remind people that we're doing with
doing beings who have rights and to
serve all those things I think that when
we can
the difference I think in the fact to
they're coming back out and they're
coming to your neighborhood so I
remember eyes to address residences
brothers and sisters are going to that
extent Saints brothers and sisters the
only difference between you and me is I
use my time better you didn't get the
opportunity or you didn't take the
opportunity I go home but you stay back
but you written your book but your next
page is empty what are you going to
write today that's the only difference
between you and me but what you write
today and I said if you write so when I
started to save brothers and sisters it
absolutely got one hundred percent
acceptance where I was sharing with them
because they felt I'm saying everything
for the benefit so there was no we and I
and you it was a week so the concept of
we in the prison he wants brings in a
faster reform so I'm there for you but
you see the second portion is that
society needs to understand that if you
punish within punishment what you it's
like punishing if you even if you won't
if you don't we don't work on reform
inside the prison we are punishing the
prisoner even more and you know what he
does he comes out and looks for the next
victim and that hurts society even more
but if you hits wiser it's more sensible
it's maturer to work on the prisoner
while easy he's captain because he
doesn't have a choice so it's easier to
work on him if you work with his time
management but it's tougher once he's
out on parole he won't bother him he
will look for the next victim because
he's determined so I think it's safer to
work on Corrections while insulin and is
more economical because the next crime
is going to be expensive back again in
society individually and and officially
because every imprisonment is expensive
so it's safer to work on reform eyes to
tell people listen what I'm doing is
actually
safer for society then not letting him
let let allowing him to be contaminated
and then look for the next victim you
know one of the foundation which I set
up a call indiavision Foundation which
works on Prison Reforms the tagline is
saved the next victim and the next
victim could be the prisoner himself or
he is looking for the next victim so
vest is when you work on the prisoner
while in prison you saving the next
victim his victimization and he looking
for the next level so you got to take
the sting out and when you start giving
him all these infrastructure support
which could be resource generated from
within you are actually here being
economical to society friends we have
five minutes left any burning questions
people who haven't had a chance to talk
I appreciate being here
good Indian see you Christy me too you
have my if ever you wish to come by the
range your visit so give me an email and
be enough to him go long show you some
of these perfect isn't India a long time
ago yeah spent three months there
actually was married in New Delhi you
which judge long time ago no it wasn't
at church it was a government ministry
well it was there was all that tobacco
stuff in the corners and all its they
called me a spinster I was 20 21 oh yeah
well you know this this idea of how nice
it would be to go to India makes me just
think the resources just the local
resources how wonderful to have dr.
Bailey tell you know of the people
sitting at this table to be helpful to
each other is also remarkable and that
was why I was hoping to get all these
people in the same you is just because
sarah said Gordon chase needs to meet
Ron Cavanaugh right it sort of fits true
right yes no currently I'm a resource to
the Indian prison I run the place cool
inside the prison with the children of
all with the children yes I run at
kindergarten inside the prison and then
I work with these children when they're
more than four years of age and put them
in residential schools are 200 children
are prisoners who with me from play way
to do the college level now because the
program started 14 years ago so I've
continued to be a resource as a
non-profit person organization to be
with the prison and I work with women I
work with women prisoners and teach them
how to weave teach them how to do
crochet etc and design and paint so they
work with me and I give them some wages
as a volunteer as a volunteer foundation
so they learn the art I give them an
honorarium for the day and children are
totally looked after by the counselors
who come from my project and you work
and once their children are four plus we
put them in residential schools where I
very good tie ups and missionary schools
so they admit me and some of my children
are in graduate classes today but I got
to win they were four years old what
would you see is the most important
thing we're going to have a Children's
Center what is the most important thing
that our children's center needs to
focus on for these mothers as parents
first of all they must this must stay
away from the muddle through the day so
you need to have a separate plate you're
never on TV but they would only be able
to come on the weekend saturday sunday
and holidays yes yes and but they must
stay with the mother or get the language
of the mother and learn the sections of
law with the mother and learn the
language of Judy quotes with the mother
so it should we have play the a normal
glading should be a normal flavor for
the children which has the kindergarten
teachers so you could even get
volunteers you can even get women some
of them who may have done these courses
to run this program for you so don't
have to wait for big budgets and they'd
be trained women also in in pre-nursery
teaching so we train women women because
then they can go go back and be sitting
mothers for some dick and serve they can
work so we teach them to become nannies
how could they be good nannies but in
your prison they were with they were
there 24 7 minutes or until they come
and take they too because they were in
the same premises we took them buy it
for the breakfast by this slept only
with the mother now I'm trying to tell
the prism they don't even send them for
this night's sleep let them stay in the
play way where we have a separate place
for them to sleep let the mothers meet
them during the day I want to further
make the change because I realize that
even sending them back there with the
during the night is not very safe so I
want the children so this is the latest
change we trying to make but during the
day they are not with the mothers when I
took over there was nothing separate for
them and they were only talking the
adult language
law and stabbings in murderers and
lawyers names that is their language
here it's written visible it's the book
is in three parts but the first part is
what I saw when I enter the prison
second is what did I do with what I saw
and the third part is what emerged how
long did it take you to make the major
change from the time that you initially
went in for six months after six months
ago started from the speed in a holistic
way which I did you it was very holistic
and then they put the key is internal
management how did I Drive the internal
management how do I community is the
prism and there was not a penny spent it
was for jet human resource generation
because I I would have not got a penny
support from Colorado but the prison
manual allowed me to do what I did it
allowed me to allow me to get a visitor
allow me to get a service like this it
did not bar it and secondly what was
silent in the rules was given by the
Supreme Court judgments that Supreme
Court judgments was saying the prison
should be doing the following and a
judgment by the Supreme Court is low so
i followed the judgments of the Supreme
Court and I followed the rules and
interpreted them positively others were
interpreting them negatively that's when
change was ok so I think that we have to
stop because our photographer George has
to get to his next venue which is there
a little thanks for making it a little
bit the like to thank you so much for
taking this time
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University